I'd like to take you all back to the
late 1950s in Sierra Leone my
93-year-old grandmother is about my age
she lives in Freetown it is hot and she
is beautiful she goes to a market one
day and she buys a yellow dress it has
stripes down it and an orange tie
attached to the collar it is also
beautiful my grandmother Isa is married
to my grandfather Harry and this dress
is the favorite of all her dresses
because it's shorter than the rest
meaning he gets to see more of her legs
she wears it a lot for herself and for
him and she brings it with her in the
1960s when she comes to England Flash
Forward six decades and I'm sitting with
her in her room in the summer of 2018
and she gives this dress to me in
trusting me with its 60-year long story
and in doing so she teaches me an
unshakable lesson about what it means to
truly value what we own that lesson
meant everything to me it meant
everything when I went to work at a
secondhand clothed tech company and it
meant everything when I left to start my
own startup SoJO a fashion Tech Solution
that's revolutionizing the clothing
repair and tailoring industry and it
continues to mean everything here today
valuing clothes that we own is not the
cultural norm I've grown as part of the
fast fashion generation which is all
about overc consumption and Hyper
disposability of clothing meaning we buy
way too much and we throw it away
without a second thought think oh I've
worn that top on Instagram so I don't
want to wear it again or this shirt has
ripped so I'm going to Chuck it and get
a new one or I've got a date lined up on
Friday so I'm going to buy a new outfit
this is how we've been taught to engage
with our clothes this is how I used to
think but engag in with clothing in this
way has an absolutely devastating cost
aside we in the global North so rarely
get to see that top from that Instagram
post that went to a charity shop instead
of being reworn it could have ended up
as one of 15 million items arriving to
the shores of Ghana each week or it
could have ended up on the mountain of
clothes in the atakama desert in Chile a
pile so big it's now viewable from space
fashion waste levels have reached 92
million metric tons to put that into
perspective because sometimes big
numbers are really hard to conceptualize
if you took every single person that
lived in Europe we're talking hundreds
of millions of people and you brought
them all together and you put them all
on one massive weighing scale they still
wouldn't be as heavy as the amount of
clothing waste we're producing annually
and it's growing and it's
unsustainable but fashion waste is only
one side of the coin we are producing so
many clothes that the fashion industry's
carbon emissions each year are more than
all international air travel so the
question is how do we go about
generating less fashion waste and in
turn reduce the amount of clothes we're
producing well to me the answer is
simple when we value clothes correctly
we care for them we repair them we alter
them to fit us even if our bodies change
we don't just throw them away and buy
more but how did I and how do we all go
about changing our mindset away from one
of disposability and towards one of
value and
Longevity well I'd like to take you to
look at my sister's genes my sister
loves these jeans ever since my parents
bought them for her 15 years ago before
a trip to Copenhagen my sister's an
artist there's nothing she loves more
than to wear these jeans when she paints
they're comfortable durable and she even
uses them as a place to wipe her
paintbrush now these genes are made of
denim which is a natural fabric a lot of
water time and care has gone into making
these genes the time and care of many
garment workers they have value but
their value has only grown over time as
their paint there are bits of paint on
these jees that match paintings around
the world think there's a bit of yellow
over here that matches yellow in a
painting in a gallery in Korea or a bit
of red on this side that matches a
painting in a home in Miami how
incredible is that my sister's worn
these jeans so much that she's had to
use SoJO to get them repaired twice
making them even more hers with every
patch making them even more valued with
every Stitch there is so much Beauty and
Power in repairing and caring for our
clothes so often sustainability can be
about the need to give something up but
for me sustainable fashion isn't about
losing anything it's about gaining a
deeper and truer happiness with the
clothes that we own more connection more
appreciation and more intentional and
personal Joy I think we can all agree
that my sister should not throw these
jeans away but that's just one example
thank but that's just one example this
pair of trousers that I've had tailored
to fit that I'm now wearing on the stage
at Ted they shouldn't be thrown away
either
neither should that dress that I bought
a couple of summers ago with my best
friend on a sunny day in a Camden
charity shop neither should that jumper
that I was wearing when my dad looked at
me and said he was proud of me clothing
can just be clothing it can be a quick
fix a passing Trend a forgettable item
that we that we wear once for that
random date or it can be something
thoughtful a material style and shape
that works for us something we want to
wear over and over again and something
that embodies the story and the
experiences of our
life every single one of us is wearing
clothing so I want you to stop for a
second and
think that top those trousers do you
know which field in which country across
the world grew that amazing cotton which
woman with what family and what life so
your SE together where have you worn
those clothes
what experiences have you had in them
will you still have them in 60 years
time why wouldn't you imagine if when
you were giving an item away you saw the
entire creation journey of that item and
you saw all the times that you'd warn it
there is no denying that responsibility
for this unsustainable system that we
live in lies with governments
legislation Corporation and Brands but
there's also no denying that we are the
ones doing the insatiable amounts of
buying and we are the ones doing the
throwing away and with that there is so
much power and opportunity for us to
collectively mve ourselves away from a
culture in which what we buy is easily
thrown away and instead move us to a
culture in which what we buy is loved
and valued
more I've just been talking about
clothing today but really I could be
talking about anything as our problems
of overc consumption and waste go far
beyond just the clothing industry we
need to buy less stuff and we need to
look after what we buy it will mean less
Global waste less Global Production and
a reduced negative impact on this planet
valuing the things that we own is a
climate
solution so next time you buy
something so next time you buy something
maybe it's a pair of jeans for a trip to
Copenhagen or maybe you're in a market
in Sierra Leone and you come across a
yellow dress I want you to think do I
need this what has it taken for this
item to get here to me in my hands what
story can I create alongside this item
and will I really truly value it thank
you